rained out yesterday so a couple of
seven inning ball games today between
the rangers and the blue jays start
number 18 on the season for ryu he's
coming off his eighth win of the season
lifted in the air to left field and hit
pretty well guriel back
on the track jumps and makes the catch
about two feet in front of the fence for
out number one
number two hitter is nate lowe the first
baseman hits one down to third
right at espinal who's got an easy play
to get him and quickly two down
for ryu here in the first inning so a
quick couple of outs
and here is the aforementioned adolesce
garcia
first pitch swinging as he often does
down to third
drop picked up and nice recovery by
espinal to get him
and how about yunjin ryu three outs on
four pitches all right a quiet top of
the first inning and so now
colby allard ready to go colby usually
works at a pretty
good clip here with nobody on base
bouncer to third culverson is on top of
it and simeon retired for the first down
of the inning
the shet hits one on the ground to short
kainer falafa is there
and his throw in plenty of time two away
and here's vladimir guerrero jr a ground
ball to short izzy backs up on this
takes a knee-high bounce off to his
glove side
and gets it over to low one two three go
the blue jays all on ground ball outs to
the left side
joey gallo leading off the second
against shan jin ryu
hit hard up the middle and drops in
there and gets past
springer gallow has a chance for extra
bases
springer's still running and so is joey
to third
they will stop him there with a stand-up
triple
or a basic and an error we'll have to
see how they scored
probably george springer looked a little
bit confused on this one he did not get
a good read on this hard-line drive it
looked a little flat-footed
when that pitch was thrown then he
completely misread that ball
the nobody out top of the second and now
john hicks the catcher
good changeup swung on and missed and
ryu picks up a strikeout for out number
one
now eli white who hit a home run in the
ninth inning of the game on friday
night 2-1 popped up
and it'll be guerrero backpedaling to
make the catch on the edge of the grass
and that is a big
second out for hyunjin ryu with joey
gallows still anchored at third
here is david dahl 3-2
outside corner at the knees and what a
job by hyunjin ryu
after the lead-off triple bottom of the
second no score the blue jays and the
rangers in buffalo the one pitch hit on
the ground left side
culverson takes the waist high hop sets
his feet and makes the good throw and
springer
is retired four up four down so far for
the jays here's t
oscar hernandez hernandez goes after all
three pitches he sees in the at-bat and
this fly ball out into right field
corralled by dahl there are two outs in
the inning
as grechik elevates here and lifts a fly
ball into center garcia
in a couple of steps to his left two
steps back to his right he makes the one
hand grab
into colby allard here six up six down
it'll be solac here in the third change
up looking good he gets solac swinging
there for his third strike out of the
ball game
two away there's a hard hit ball by
kinder
philippa for a base hit rangers second
hit of the ball game against ryu
and two on with two out now with
adolesce garcia coming out it's on their
way
[Applause]
did stay with a change up down and away
get some swinging and strands a couple
of runners
no score going bottom three colby allard
who's been
excellent so far fired all six hitters
to his face
with a little swinging bun up the third
baseline and allard's not even going to
try to make a throw he'll just concede
the infield single
for goriel to begin the bottom of the
third and that'll bring up now santiago
espinal
espinal lines one down the left field
line that's going to drop in fair
gorielle around a third on a double by
santiago espinal who continues to do a
nice job of the bat so second and third
one down
marcus simeone who grounded out his
first time up
yeah goriel coming home on a soft
bouncer to third so
simeon brown ball to third to drive in a
run goriel comes in to score one nothing
blue jay's bottom three
now runner with second two down for bo
bashed first pitch to machete
and he smokes it into center for a base
hit espinal around third
on his way home the throw is way high as
he slides in safely
two nothing blue jays blue jays are the
best
team in baseball when they step into
that batter's box and hitting that first
pitch
so everybody's gotta be on your toes the
pitchers the inferiors and the face
runners we go to the fourth toronto two
texas nothing
there's a ground ball off the bat of
joey gallo weekly hit out to second
among kasimian onto first and that's
nice to get gallow
on the first pitch and the ground ball
down to third
right at espinal and the wide throw
but guerrero still gets the glove on him
going to buy had to come
way off the bag but got a swipe tag on
hicks for out number two
so george springer now two for two and
his stolen base attempts this season and
he moves into scoring position
has already had an infield hit in this
game couldn't have rolled it up the
third baseline any better and another
swinging bun up the third base line
hugging the line
hugging the line staying fair for a base
hit
that's unbelievable springer to third a
lot of times you'll see bald roll
up there the dirt area and it'll roll
foul
but in buffalo nope and donated
nope and the benefactor of that lourdes
gorilla is going to get a second hit
i mean that thing stayed right there
he's loving that two-nothing toronto
lead
jansen the number nine hitter now danny
jansen first pitch swinging
belts it to left and it's gone number
five on the season for jansen it is
three to nothing blue jays another first
pitch home run by the jays
danny jansen turns the trick this time
so three nothing blue jays their 32nd
first pitch home run of the season that
leads the majors
the engine ryu pitching into the sixth
with a very low pitch count
in a seven inning game this one
out to left field and it definitely
crossed up guriel
i don't know it would have mattered
either way but low
as a one out double just the third hit
this afternoon for the
rangers adolesce garcia swings grounds
one to short runner back to second
as beshette throws garcia out two down
1-0 and that's a fair ball out in front
of the play chanson's got it down to
first
and the side is retired three-nothing
blue jays going to the bottom of the six
two in scoring position and the batter
is randall grichik the 2-0
and gretchen gets it in the air to deep
center garcia go in the back
makes the catch a couple of feet from
the fence
but tagging and scoring springer
hernandez comes to third
rbi for grizzik four-nothing blue chase
this is right-hander josh spores comes
out of the texas bullpen the infield in
for alertis goriel jr
1-1 and he hits it sharply to solac at
second and the run will come in to score
so hernandez going on contact
solac thought about the plate but
settles for the out at first it's five
nothing
well hyunjin ryu with the benefit of
extra rest whether that's been a factor
or not who knows
but he has been terrific today 2-2
reaching for it ground ball to third
espinal with plenty of time and the
throw on the money one down 80 pitches
through six and a third
for ryu and the o2 swung on and in the
air to center field should be routine
for springer and it is two down and ryu
is one out away from a complete game
this would be a couple of nice
milestones for ryu if he can get this
one last out
the 1-0 to doll swung on to center field
well hit
springer still going back but he'll make
the play on the track
and the blue jays will win it young ryu
goes the distance allowing just three
hits seven
score this inning he shuts out the
rangers five to nothing